et pour être plus précis famille de
gynécologues ait gagné 6 ans lorsque un
gynéco ce quelqu'un qui donne la vie
tous les jours
bien sûr que mon frère et gynéco mon
père est jeune et croma seraient gynéco
arrêta toujours les discussions de
gynéco tu sais mon père si l'état fait
quoi cette semaine syrie puis j'ai
accouché 20 femmes je donnais 20 fois la
vie ma soeur bah moi j'ai sauvé la vie
d'un enfant in extremis est vrai et
auris toi t'as fait quoi tu fais le fou
la poule
julien courbet très inquiet parce que ça
tu es très gênante quand même un général
on dira un sapeur hiroire le mac
attention c'est parti de là
[Rires]
il est comment papa c'est moi qui était
dévote
il est comment ils jouent bien papa
c'est un bon wagon
il est marrant pateras et des baux de 6
1 tu aimes ce que fait papa gestion six
films thème ses films
je peux citer d'autres films de papa le
cast est porteuse d espoir hier c'est
qu'il vient de citer toute ma
filmographie pour